ثلاثه عشر قتيلا بينهم ثلاثه من قاده حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي
بغارات اسرائيليه على غزه
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه تطالب بتدخل دولي
والجهات تقول ان الرد على اسرائيل لن
يتاخر
اسرائيل اسرائيل تستدعي جزءا من قوات
الاحتياط وبن غفير يطالب بتغيير السياسه
تجاه قطاع غزه
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اهلا بكم
صباح الخير مشاهدينا اعلنت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه ارتفاعها حصيله ضحايا الغارات
الاسرائيليه على غزه الى 13 قتيلا بينهم
اربعه اطفال وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن
عن مقتل قائد منطقه شمال قطاع غزه في حركه
الجهاد وقياديا بارز في الحركه واميني سر
المجلس العسكري فيها في عمليه مشتركه تمت
بالتنسيق بين الجيش والمخابرات
الاسرائيليه واستهدفت مواقع لحركه الجهاد
ومنازل لقادته في القطاع الجيش الاسرائيلي
افاد بمقتل القيادي في سرايا القدس وقائد
لواء غزه خليل البهتيني في العمليه وافاد
بمقتل القيادي في حركه الجهاد طارق عز
الدين في القصف الاسرائيلي كما ادى القصف
الاسرائيلي الى مقتل جهاد غنام القيادي في
الحركه وزوجته وزاره الصحه في القطاع
افادت بسقوط نحو 13 قتيلا وعشرين جريحا
الجيش اعلن مواصله ضرباته على غزه كما
اعلن اغلاق طرق ومواقع وطالب بالانتقال
الى الطرقات بديله في مناطق غلاف غزه هذا
واكد الاعلام الاسرائيلي ان رئيس الوزراء
سيعقد اجتماعا اليوم للحكومه الامنيه
المصغره المكتب الحكومي في غزه اعلن بدوره
تعليق الدوامات والدراسه فيما اكدت حركه
الجهاد من جانبها مقتل قياديها وقالت انها
لن تغادر مواقعها وانها سترد من حيث انتهت
اخر مواجهه مع اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
وهددت حركه الجهات في قطاع غزه اسرائيل
بان ردها لن يتاخر على هجمات تل ابيب
والتي استهدفت مواقع الحركه في القطاع فجر
اليوم وحملت الحركته اسرائيل كامل
المسؤوليه عما وصفته بالمجزره الارهابيه
والتي اكدت انها تشكل انتهاكا خطيرا لوقف
اطلاق النار وفق بيان الحركه ونعت حركه
الجهاد 13 فلس بينهم اطفال وثلاثه من قاده
الحركه قتلوا بعد غارات جويه اسرائيليه
استهدفتهم في قطاع غزه
[موسيقى]
معنى مباشره من المنطقه الجنوبيه بالقرب
من حدود غزه مدير مكتب العربيه في فلسطين
زياد حلبي اهلا بك معنا زياد اذا ما الذي
يحدث ما الجديد في هذه الاستهدافات
والاشتباكات بين الاسرائيليين والحركه
التصعيد الاساسي لم يبدا بعد بعد طبعا
الاغتيالات الاسرائيليه هناك حال ترقب
الان على هذه الجبهه من في منطقه حدود
قطاع غزه طبعا اغلقت المنطقه الحدوديه
بالكامل وطلب من المستوطنين حتى 40
كيلومترا عن حدود القطاع بالبقاء بالقرب
من الملاجئ
التحسبا من بدء عمليه اطلاق الصواريخ
التقديرات عمليا في اسرائيل بانه مع بعد
تشييع القاده الثلاثه والضحيه ممن قتلتهم
اسرائيل في الغارات قد تبدا عمليه الرد
الصاروخي من قبل سرايا القدس الجناح
العسكري للجهاد الاسلامي الذي تعهد التي
تعهدت عمليا بالرد كما اسلفتي في المقدمه
على هذه المجزره البشعه كما وصفتها
وبالتالي هناك الان حال تاهب تم نشر
بطاريات القبه الحديديه ليس فقط في
المنطقه الجنوبيه لانها موجوده هنا وانما
في تل ابيب اسرائيل وايضا على الحدود
الشماليه مع لبنان وسوريا تحسبا من تفعيل
الجبهات المختلفه بسبب هذا التصعيد السؤال
بالنسبه لاسرائيل هل سيكون رد الجهاد في
اطار قواعد الاشتباك المتعارف عليها بمعنى
حتى اربعين كيلو مترا وبالتالي يمكن
احتواء الوضع ام انها قد تبحث عن
علامه فارقه لهذه المواجهه مثل قصف مطار
تل ابيب كما فعلت في المرات الماضيه هي
كانت كان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد اعلن زياد
بانهم يعني طلبوا من الذين يعيشون في
بلدات تقع في محيط اربعين كيلو متر من غزه
بالبقاء قرب الملاجئ حتى يوم الخميس اذا
ربما هذه اشاره بانهم سيلتزمون بهذه
القاعده
هناك توقع اسرائيلي بذلك هذا ليس اكيدا
ابدا
وبالتالي هذا يدلل على ما قلناه منذ ساعات
الصباح بان اسرائيل تتوقع ربما اياما من
القتال مع الجهاد الاسلامي تحديدا رغم ان
الفصائل الاخرى وخاصه حماس طبعا وهو ما
يعني اسرائيل لان لديها قدرات اكبر بكثير
صاروخيه ايضا تعهدت بالرد على اسرائيل
بهذا المعنى هذا يدلل على ان اسرائيل
عمليا
تقرا الوضع بان ثمه تصعيدا قادما اجرت
اتصالات مع مصر مسبقا عمليا بعد
الاغتيالات وقالت انها يمكن ان تتوقف في
حال لم يكن هناك رد ولكن طبعا هذا امر ليس
جديا لان الرد سياتي من خلال اطلاق عشرات
الصواريخ دفعه واحده ربما بعد ساعه او
ساعتين من هذا الرد المتوقع من الفصائل
وخلال الساعات القليله القادمه
زياد هل هذا ما نفهمه
هذا صحيح جدا كما قلنا في السابق الجهاد
الاسلامي تملك قدرات صاروخيه وصواريخ
عمليا
يمكن ان نقول بانها دقيقه نوعا ما يمكن
لها ان تصل الى مدن بعيد يمكن ان ترو الان
مقاتلات اف 16 في الاجواء المحيطه بقطاع
غزه لا ادري ان كانت العدسه من هنا
تلتقطها اعتقد نعم الان ترون على الشاشه
مباشره مقاتله اف 16 اسرائيليه عمليا هذا
المشهد نراه تباعا في هذه المنطقه تحليق
مكثف للمقاتلات الاسرائيليه بالاضافه الى
مئات ربما من المسيرات التي تراقب قطاع
غزه منذ عمليه الاغتيال وحتى الان عمليا
لم تترك الاجواء في هذه المرحله تحسبا
للتصعيد الذي قد يكون كما قلت بعد وقت
وجيز من هذه اللحظه هل هناك توقعات بان
تتزامن
يعني القصف والرد من الحركه حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي او حتى من حماس مع تشييع جتامين
القتلى ربما
هذا هذا صحيح موفقه مصادر عمليا في حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي قالت انه بعد تشييع
الشهداء قد يكون الرد عمليا ولكن رسميا
طبعا لم يعلن ذلك التوقعات بشكل عام
والتقديرات هو فعلا بان هناك ربما حاجه
لاتاحه تشييع كبير
للقاده الثلاثه التابعين للجهاد ولمن
عمليا سقطوا في هذا في هذه الاغتيالات
وبعدها فقط يبدا الرد بالصواريخ على المدن
الاسرائيليه السؤال الاكبر بالنسبه
لاسرائيل يتالف من جزئين الجزء الاول هل
تكتفي الجهاد بقواعد الاشتباك المتبعه
بمعنى حتى 40 كيلومترا
المستوطنات والمدن البعيده عن قطاع غزه ام
انها تذهب الى ما هو ابعد من ذلك الى
استهداف تل ابيب عمليا او حتى القدس الامر
الاخر هل تشارك حماس فعليا بشكل كبير في
هذه المواجهه ام لا الاوضاع تذكر كثيرا
بما حدث قبل عام عندما كانت حكومه لافيد
عمليا في السلطه بادرت ايضا الى اغتيال
قاده في الجهاد الاسلامي وكان هناك مواجهه
من اربعه ايام للتذكير فقط في حينها على
ما اذكر بان الجهاد الاسلامي استهدفت تل
ابيب ومطار بن غوريون ثلاثه مرات على
الاقل اذا يعني تتوقع زياده ان نرى ذات
الرد هذه المرض ولكن هناك انباء تتحدث عن
اجتماع للحكومه الاسرائيليه المصغره ماذا
نتوقع من هذا الاجتماع
الاجتماع عند السابعه مساء كما اعلن صباح
هذا اليوم هذا الاجتماع سيكون لتقييم
اليوم الاول من مالات الامور على صعيد هذه
الجوله من التصعيد على جبهه قطاع غزه
عندها يكون قد فهم الامر الى اين تذهب
الامور في هذه في هذا التصعيد بمعنى هل هي
قواعد الاشتباك المتعارف عليها عمليا حتى
40 كيلومترا ورد اسرائيلي بالغارات على
المواقع التابعه للجهاد او لحركه حماس في
قطاع غزه ام لا هناك تفعيل لجبهات اخرى
هناك مدى مدى صواريخ مختلف هذه كلها تكون
واضحه لكن القرارات عمليا كانت اتخذت
سابقا منذ اسابيع قرار الاغتيال لم يتخذ
بالامس عمليا وينفذ وانما اتخذ قبل اسابيع
بهذا المعنى وعندما افتعل وزير الامن
الداخلي الاسرائيلي بن جبير هذه الازمه مع
نتنياهو بسب ب هزاله ما وصفها بهزاله الرد
على قطاع غزه الثلاثاء الماضي ربما كان
يعرف بان هناك اغتيالا مبيتا وكان في اطار
عمليات التمويه ايضا
طيب زياده يعني ذكرت في بدايه حديثنا بان
كان هناك اتصال بين الجانب الاسرائيلي
والجانب المصري هل نتوقع اي محاولات مصريه
للتهدئه
هذا صحيح جدا وكما قلنا نتوقع ان يكون
السيناريو مشابها بغض النظر عن مالات
الامور ان كانت تصعيد سيتطور الى حرب ام
لا في نهايه المطاف السيناريو يبدو مشابها
في كل المرات اعلان وقف اطلاق نار برعايه
او بواسطه مصريه عمليا مفاده بان الجانبين
يوقفان اطلاق النار وبالتالي هذا قد يتكرر
هذه المره السؤال بعد ماذا هل بعد يوم او
يومين من القتال على هذه الجبهه ام اننا
امام ربما تصعيد اكبر وحرب شامله قد تستمر
فتره اطول هذا لا نستطيع ان نجيب عليه
طبعا في هذه المرحله قبل ان يبدا الرد
الصاروخي المتوقع على المدن الاسرائيليه
طيب شكرا لك مباشره من المنطقه الجنوبيه
بالقرب من حدود غزه مدير مكتب العربيه في
فلسطين زياد حلبي سنبقى معك في اي جديد
بكل تاكيد
وفيما قالت حركه الجهاد ان ردها على
اسرائيل لن يتاخر دانت الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه الغارات الاسرائيليه على قطاع
غزه معتبره اياها تصعيدا خطيرا يهدد
بتفجير الصراع بالكامل كما وطالبت
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه في بيان لها طلبت
المجتمع الدولي بتدخل عاجل مؤكده ان
الحاله السياسيه تفوضي للصراع هو المدخل
الوحيد لتحقيق الامن والاستقرار
[تصفيق]
واظهر مقطع فيديو اثار الدمائر التي وقع
في البنايه السكنيه وسط قطاع غزه والتي
قتل فيها القيادي طارق عز الدين في حركه
الجهاد
[موسيقى]
مريم يلا
سبحان الله
وصف وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار
بن غفير وصف العمليات الامنيه التي شنتها
قوات بلاده في قطاع غزه بالبدايه الجيده
داعيا الى تغيير سياسه اسرائيل في القطاع
ونقلا عن صحيفه تايمز اوفريل قال بن غفير
انه يهنئ رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
على العمليه الاستباقيه في غزه مجردا الى
انها بدايه موفقه
من قطاع غزه تنضم الينا الصحفيه روان
الصوراني اهلا بك معنا روان بدايه لنتحدث
عن الوضع في الميدان هل هناك زياده في
الاصابات هل هناك زياده في عدد الوفيات
حتى الان الذي وصل الى 13 بحسب الانباء
صحيح الاحصائيه الاخيره الصادره عن وزاره
الصحه بغزه تشير الى ارتقاء
ثلاث عشره ضحيه من بينهم اربعه اطفال
واربعه سيدات اضافه الى عشرين اصابه
لمواطنين بجراح مختلفه بين الخطيره
والمتوسطه من بينهم ثلاث اطفال وسبع سيدات
ايضا مدير مستشفى الشفاء بغزه الدكتور
محمد ابو سلميه اشاره بان استمرار هذا
التصعيد على غزه سيدفع او سيزيد من معاناه
مستشفيات القطاع التي تعاني اصلا منذ اشهر
من
ضعف وترهل ونقص في الادوات والمستلزمات
الطبيه خاصه وان قطاع غزه ومنذ
ظهرا
تسمح اسرائيل باد الاجهزه الطبيه
التشخيصيه اليه وهذا التصعيد قد يفاقم من
ازمه
المستلزمات الطبيه في قطاع غزه حيث منع
ادخال هذه الاجهزه يشكل تحديا كبيرا امام
عمل الطواقم الطبيه التي يعني من جانبها
جميعها اعلنت حاله الاستنفار كافه
مستشفيات القطاع اعلنت حاله الطوارئ
والطواقم الطبيه البشريه جاهزه لاستقبال
الاصابات غير ان الامكانيات الطبيه هي
التي تقف حائلا دون اسعاف المواطنين بشكل
كامل بالنسبه للميدان ايضا لجنه المتابعه
للقوى الوطنيه والاسلاميه بغزه قبل قليل
اعلنت الكتاب الوطني والاضراب الشامل وذلك
يعني
بما جرى صباح هذه الليله جراء
استهداف ثلاثه من ابرز القاده العسكريين
للجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
واضافه الى عوائلهم وهذا لربما ما اسرار
ايضا ح وتخوفات ورد فعل كان يعني عنيف في
كافه لربما او قاسم في كافه البيانات التي
صدرت عن الفصائل والتي جميعها وصفت ما جرى
بالجريمه وبان من يتحمل تبعات هذه الجريمه
هو اسرائيل بالدرجه الاولى الجهات
الاسلامي ايضا اصدرت بيانا قالت بان الرد
من قبل الجهاد الاسلامي لن يتاخر ولا
نتهاون في الرد على دماء شعبنا فيما يتعلق
بالواقع المعيشي والامكاني في غزه نتحدث
الان عن حاله اغلاق عامه لكافه المعادن
الحدوديه سواء معابر الخاصه بالبضائ ع مع
ابو سالم
مع غزه كذلك اغلاق تام لحركه امام حركه
الصيادين اذا نحن نتحدث الان عن شلل كان
في الحركه التجاريه لنقل في غزه التي
تستوعب يوميا الاف البضائع ونحن نتحدث عن
بقعه مقتظه بالسكان نتحدث عن اكثر من
اثنين مليون مواطن يحتاجون لمستلزمات
اساسيه وغذائيه ويحتاجون للغاز
وخلاف ذلك اغلاق هذه المعابر يشكل تهديدا
معيشيا وانسانيا للاثنين مليون اكثر من
اثنين مليون مواطن في قطاع غزه اضافه الى
التخوفات الانسانيه يعني نحن نتحدث عن
طفله فقدت والدها من ضمن الضحايا الذين
تاثروا جراء استهداف القيادي من الجهاد
الاسلامي احد القاده بمدينه غزه هناك
عائله [__] فيها الاب والزوجه والابن وبقيت
الطفله لتعاني ويلات اليوتوم في الايام
القادمه طفله صغيره لا تتجاوز الست اعوام
يعني هذا المشهد بشكل بشكل عام هناك حاله
ترقب ايضا من قبل الشارع الفلسطيني في غزه
لرد الفصائل وهنا يعني يمكننا القول بان
هناك اختلاف في رد الفصائل الفلسطينيه حيث
لم ياتي الرد بشكل مباشر كما تم التوقع
الجميع كان متوقع في ساعات الصباح
ترد الفصائل الفلسطينيه على ما جرى ليله
امس ولكن لربما الواضح ان الفصائل
بتاخرها تتبنى استراتيجيه جديده لربما في
الرد على
به اسرائيل بمباغه للقاده العسكريين
اسرائيل وصفت ما قامت به بانه عمليه ناجحه
وادعت بانها استهدفت 10 مواقع تتبع لمواقع
عسكريه وبالفعل ايضا برفع التاهب الامني
استعدادا لاي رد شكرا جزيلا لك من قطاع
غزه الصحفيه روان الصوراني
افادت مصادر بسماع عدوي انفجار قوي وسط
مدينه نابلس بالضفه الغربيه وذكرت وسائل
اعلام فلسطينيه ان القوات الاسرائيليه
الخاصه اقتحمت البلده القديمه في مدينه
نابلس صباح اليوم في مقاله مصادر محليه
فلسطينيه ان القوات الاسرائيليه تحاصر
منزلا في حي الياسمينه وسط اشتباكات دائره
في البلده القديمه بين الجيش الاسرائيلي
ومسلحين فلسطينيين في الوقت ذاته افادت
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي بان القوات تنفذ
عمليه امنيه في نابلس حاليا
فاصل ونعود
احييكم من جديد نعود مباشره او نذهب الى
كلمه للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين الذي القاها قبل قليل ان نشاهد
امامنا على الشاشه
احتفالات النصر والتي القى فيها قبل قليل
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين كلمه في هذه
المناسبه
[موسيقى]
قالت الاداره العسكريه في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه فان انظمه الدفاع الجوي تتصدى
لهجمات روسيه على المدينه بعد اطلاق دارات
جويه في عموم البلاد تاتي هجمات اليوم
بعدما اطلقت روسيا اكبر هجماتها بالطائرات
المسيره حتى الان في اطار حمله جويه
بداتها قبل عشره ايام بعد فتره هدوء منذ
اوائل مارس
[موسيقى]
قال قائد الجيش السوداني الفريق اول ركن
عبد الفتاح البرهان قال خلال اتصال هاتفي
بالرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان الجيش
منفتح على اي مبادره تسهم في تخفيف
الاعمال التي وصفها بالوحشيه من قبل الدعم
السريع ومن جانبه اعرب الرئيس التركي عن
شكره لحكومه السودان على تقديمها الدعم
للسفير والجاليه التركيه وعلى موافقتها
لنقل السفاره لبورت سودان كما طلب اردوغان
المساعده في نقل بقيه الجاليه التركيه من
الخرطوم ونيالا الى بورتسودان
وقال رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان ان الجيش السوداني اقترب
من انهاء وجود الدعم السريع في الخرطوم
وعبر البرهان في تصريحات ادلى بها للاعلام
المصري عن شكره للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
على استضافتها للمفاوضات الهادفه لوقف
القتال في السودان كما اعرب البرهان عن
خشيه القوات المسلحه من انتقال الحرب الى
ولايات السودان الاخرى مشرا الى استحاله
الحديث عن اي موعد لوقف اطلاق النار حاليا
خاصه في ظل تمركز قوات الدعم السريع في
الاحياء السكنيه مجددا في الوقت ذاته على
ان الحل السلمي هو الطريق الامثل لحل
الازمه الحاليه في السودان
في الختام نذكر دوما بابرز العناوين
13 قتيلا بينهم ثلاثه من قاده حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي بغارات اسرائيليه على غزه
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه تطالب بتدخل دولي
والجهاز تقول ان الرد على اسرائيل لن
يتاخر
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات